hey youtubers is Charlie so a lot of you
guys requested a video on the Horn of
winter and Dragon binder a couple of
enchanted horns and Game of Thrones just
the two that we've heard about since we
haven't seen dragon binder on the show
I'm gonna talk about that second I'll do
like a special spoiler warning so if you
don't want to hear about that you can't
on the flip side of that the show has
done a version of the Horn of winter as
its described in the book so we'll just
start with that if you don't remember
the Horn of winter it was kind of an
offhanded thing people kind of expected
it to be a really big deal because mance
rayder hyped it up big time we as
readers and as show Watchers learn about
it as Mance Rayder is talking to Jon
Snow about it he just he tells John that
he's going to blow it and it will bring
the wall crashing down but as we can see
mance rayder got put to the torch that
did not happen the Horn of winter is
actually known as the Horn of your minh
your minh was just one of the ancient
kings beyond the wall is about eight
feet long and it's supposed to be like
so big the horn itself like the outer
rim is supposed to be so big that Jon
can fit his arm in from about the elbow
to the tip of his knuckles and so you
get you get an idea for how big it's
supposed to be the closest we got on the
show is Samwell and a couple of the
other brothers the Nights Watch finding
this horn wrapped up with a bunch of
dragonglass
so clearly much smaller than the one
that's described in the books suddenly
you can hear the air being let I have a
balloon somewhere but this might have
been the show telling us that the Horn
of winter is a complete legend
it has gold bands with runes of the
first men drawn all over it man says
that it's supposedly woke the Giants
from the earth whenever it was blown and
he told the story about it being able to
bring the wall crashing down because the
wall is enchanted the books haven't
really explained specifically what those
enchantments are like the mechanics
behind them only that there is power but
it all kind of seemed like it ended up
going nowhere George or Martin seemed
like he was hyping it up then it gets
destroyed and in the context of the show
that they just present this broken horn
like it doesn't even look like it works
so I think it's a good example of
legends with a lot of half-truths in the
game of Thrones universe like yes this
was probably a big thing you know it's
very special there are some magical
properties but it's not quite as special
as you think it is George R Martin is a
big fan of talking but it's not like the
Ring of Power where you see something
they say it's special and it ends up
being the most special thing ever
myrn is also a big geek on real world
history so it's like saying some ancient
Roman artifact was really really special
but you see it in real life and it's
like well it's really shiny but I you
know it doesn't seem like it's
super-powerful like everyone said it was
if you remember at the end of season 4
whenever the wildlings were marching on
the wall Mance Rayder was trying to take
his army through the wall when that
happened in the books there was just the
threat of the horn and you know
obviously everything kind of went down
in a similar way in tormund Giantsbane
is thinking to John if only I had the
horn you know things would have gone
very very differently you guys would
have been sorry and John kind of Wonders
to himself if maybe Mance Rayder was
lying about the horn you know is there a
real Horn of winter out there somewhere
that just hasn't been found yet so it's
possible that there is a Horn of winter
somewhere in the north that is capable
of bringing the wall down and the one
that we saw in the books and the one
that we saw on this show is not that
true horn you guys can let me know do
you feel like the Horn of winter is an
actual real thing like you feel like it
exists and Mance Rayder just had
something that was not the Horn of
winter or do you think it's Martin just
messing with us a little bit do you
think it's actually not a real thing
most of the legends that we've seen like
the old man's legends for instance have
actually come true and in certain ways I
mean not all of them so far
but as far as we've seen like we've seen
the White Walkers we've seen the night's
king so most of the time it seems like
the legends on Game of Thrones that are
told are at least half true usually if
you know people just misinterpret things
which kind of fits with Martin's theme
of the story being true to life I do
definitely think that the wall will come
crashing down sometime during the series
you know probably not till like season 8
but I don't think it's gonna be as
simple as the night's king just like
riding up with a giant horn and blowing
it and just bringing it crashing down I
feel like it's gonna be much more
complicated than that that would
definitely suck if the night's king had
the actual Horn of winter but given that
it's a device that was supposedly
designed by the First Men you think that
it would be harmful to White Walkers so
they wouldn't be able to use it it'd be
like them trying to use a Valyrian blade
like it would probably burn their hands
that's another interesting thought too
because just because it has golden bands
on it doesn't necessarily mean that the
runes are Valyrian steel Valyrian steel
itself doesn't really have color like it
just looks like other steel you can add
color to it dragon binder is an entirely
different matter though so let's move on
to that so just careful
for spoilers for euron greyjoy in the
books this is something that the show
has skipped over we might see it in
season six but where we are in the books
right now like the show has already
passed that like it's part of the
Ironborn storyline that the show skipped
so in book four we learn about the
dragon horn now this is a horn called
dragon binder by euron greyjoy
he claims he found it in the smoking
ruins of ancient Fallujah so likely that
place where Jorah and Tyrion went in
season five he just claims he found it
there we didn't actually see him go
there he just shows up and starts
talking about it like look at this
awesome thing that I found down in the
ruins of ancient Valyria it's not quite
as big as the Horn of winter but it's
still really big it has Valyrian glyphs
all over it that glow red whenever you
blow the horn the way air on Greyjoy
describes it is actually really cool he
says bright and baneful was its voice a
shivering hot scream that made a man's
bones seem to thrum within him it is the
Horn of hell he's just saying that the
sound that the horn makes is really
scary
it's meant to be heard by dragons so of
course it sounds kind of weird as of
right now it is completely untested like
no one has tried to blow it in the
vicinity of a dragon as the characters
talked about it the ancient Valyria pnes
used the horns to control dragons like
you would use a dog whistle it seems
like the show is casting euron greyjoy
there's definitely a pirate character
that sounds like him so we might see a
version of dragon binder on this show
but thus far there haven't been a whole
lot of Enchanted items that the books
have talked about the show the show just
typically skips over them the most
enchanted things that we've seen so far
are like the Valyrian swords like when
John is fighting the White Walkers what
I'm hoping is is that as the show gets
into season six seven and eight like as
it slowly starts moving to the climax we
start seeing more and more powerful
magic but it stands to reason being a
Valyrian horn that the power behind
dragon binder might be related to the
red God and because the Horn of winter
was built by the first men its power
might be tied to the old gods which I
still considered to be separate entities
there are a lot of theories that in Game
of Thrones the many different gods that
people talk about or just different ways
of describing a single or like one or
two gods like maybe the many-faced God
is the same thing as the red God or the
great other for that matter that's just
something to think about as the show
moves into season six ice
still consider a lot of the Gods to be
different different types of magic
exists so it stands to reason that there
are also probably different types of
gods so here's a little bit question for
you guys if the show does do your uncle
a joy if that ends up being a thing do
you think that we'll see a version of
the Dragon horn on the show like will
they start finding artifacts in ancient
literature or will they start turning up
Daenerys dragons do seem like they're
going a little bit crazy like you're
getting a little bit out of control but
as we saw with Daenerys and drove on she
still has a very strong connection to
him so it's completely possible that the
show could just skip over the dragon
horn or if we do see a dragon horn it
would just be like a visual easter egg
it it'd just be like you know pile of
Valyrian gifts that someone brings her
usually the show tries to be kind of
economic with the things that it does
like the stories that it tells so if
Daenerys is already able to control her
dragons you know with with her mind
League like the bond that she has with
them then what does she need a horn for
the story the books is a little bit
different the direction it's going with
Joran Greyjoy Victarion
the Ironborn people so we'll see how
winds of winter plays out but if George
our Martin finishes it in time we will
actually be able to compare winds of
winter with season six episodes as far
as we know Dan and Dave don't have any
idea what goes on in winds of winter
they just they have a general idea of
where the characters are headed and a
lot of you guys ask like how I think the
show is gonna end compared to the books
I think that they'll end in relatively
similar ways it'll be that bittersweet
Return of the King ending that George R
Martin talked about but he actually said
that he's a big fan of the way talking
ended Lord of the Rings it's not gonna
end in like a giant big swarm Avengers
moment just a quick reminder the new
round of the giveaway all you have to do
to enter is be a subscriber and leave a
comment on this video because this video
is posting a day late my Game of Thrones
Q&A will just post tomorrow but I am
working on a Q&A for all the big Marvel
stuff that happened over the weekend
like Captain America Civil War and
Doctor Strange so that will post next
why you guys wait for that it seems like
we may have gotten some unofficial
confirmation of Tower of joy in season
six so if you don't know what the Tower
of joy is in the game of Thrones
universe you can click here to learn all
about that and you can click here to
learn all about Arthur Dayne because it
seems like the show is gonna do him -
thank you so much for watching everybody
let's high five I'll see you guys
tonight
you